[Aplausos]
[Música]
puede que no nos guste pero no se puede
decir que la corrupción en la argentina
como en la inmensa mayor parte de los
países sea algo precisamente nuevo lo
cierto es que ya desde la primera junta
de gobierno allá por 1810 prácticamente
ningún gobierno argentino ha estado
libre de sospecha
que claro las posibilidades son casi
infinitas y los incentivos muy generosos
y no no os penséis que simplemente es
meter la mano y ya la mayoría de los
casos de corrupción son mucho más
enrevesados sin embargo amigos lo que se
ha destapado en los últimos tiempos
especialmente con el caso de los
cuadernos va mucho más allá estamos
hablando de la constatación de que la
argentina ha existido un proceso
sistemático liderado por el propio
gobierno de la nación con el objetivo de
saquear a gran escala las arcas públicas
del país
[Música]
y ojo porque no estamos hablando de
alguna que otra comisión sino de miles y
miles de millones de dólares que todo
apunta a que fueron robados durante los
gobiernos peronistas de néstor kirchner
y cristina fernández de kirchner
las novedades se suceden prácticamente a
diario pero nuestro objetivo con este
vídeo es contaros cómo comenzó en qué
consistía y cómo funcionaba una trama en
la que está implicada la mismísima
presidencia de la república- así como
decenas de políticos jueces funcionarios
y muchos de los más importantes
empresarios del país
amigos la trama de los cuadernos comenzó
con la llegada a la presidencia de
argentina de néstor kirchner en mayo de
2003 y continuó bajo la presidencia de
su esposa cristina fernández de kirchner
hasta el año 2015 es decir más de una
década de saqueo sistemático de las
arcas públicas ahora bien antes de ver
en qué consistía y cuánta plata le ha
supuesto a los argentinos tenemos
algunas preguntas que contestar sobre
los auténticos protagonistas de esta
historia por supuesto los kirchner
quienes son como se hicieron con el
poder como lograron poner en marcha la
que tal vez sea la mayor operación de
expolio de toda la historia de la
argentina
atentos viva la patria
[Música]
el ascenso de los kirchner
dos políticos de provincia que lograron
convertirse durante años en los dueños
de la argentina amigos todo esto comenzó
ni más ni menos que con una bonita
historia de amor entre los jóvenes
universitarios
néstor y cristina se conocieron a
mediados de los años 70 mientras
estudiaban derecho en la universidad
nacional de la plata en buenos aires- el
amor surgió muy pronto y en 1976 tras el
golpe militar liderado por el teniente
general jorge rafael videla nuestros dos
enamorados decidieron marcharse a
ejercer como abogados a la ciudad de río
gallegos en la provincia de santa cruz
una ciudad que por cierto está lejísimos
de la capital ni más ni menos que a dos
mil seiscientos cincuenta kilómetros
vamos que si nos hubieran preguntado en
aquella época por el futuro político de
esta pareja probablemente la política
nacional no habría sido una respuesta
sin embargo tras el regreso de la
democracia en 1983 esta bonita pareja de
abogados comenzó a militar en el partido
peronista y ahí fue amigos cuando
verdaderamente se puso en marcha la
carrera de quienes llegaron a ser los
underwood argentinas por ahora que lo
pienso creo que fueron los underwood
quienes llegaron a ser los kirchner de
la serie de política una relación por y
para el poder primero en 1987
néstor kirchner fue elegido intendente
de río gallegos
alcalde unos años más tarde en 1991
gobernador de la provincia de santa cruz
y finalmente en 2003 presidente de la
república de argentina por su parte
cristina fernández durante este tiempo
no se quedó al margen hizo carrera en
las cámaras legislativas diputada
provincial diputada nacional y senadora
nacional hasta llegar en 2007 a la
presidencia de la república y luego en
2015 devuelta al senado
parece que los kirchner lo tuvieron muy
pero que muy claro entre la abogacía y
la política la política más de 30 años
viviendo de los contribuyentes eso sí
que es una carrera sin embargo espera un
momento yo tenía una determinada
teníamos cinco una determinada posición
económica y que ha sido producto
bueno es que he trabajado toda mi vida
he sido una muy exitosa abogada para su
exitosa presidencia también
la provincia de santa cruz que es donde
comenzaron los kirchner su carrera
política no sólo está lejísimos de la
capital que al fin y al cabo es el
centro del poder sino que en 2001 su
población no llegaba a los 200 mil
habitantes más o menos un 0,5 por ciento
de toda la población del país que en
aquel momento era de 36 millones 260 mil
personas
entonces cómo es posible que dos
políticos de un lugar tan lejano del
poder y tan pequeño pudieran hacerse con
el control de todo el país esta es la
pregunta que durante largo tiempo se han
hecho muchos periodistas y analistas
políticos pues bien ahora estamos
empezando a conocer la respuesta
básicamente amigos el matrimonio fue
copando cooptando y comprando casi todos
los sectores de la política argentina a
golpe de billetera porque nosotros
no lucramos clarín no lucramos tenemos
convicciones tenemos ideas clarín no
lucramos no estamos en el negocio de la
política estamos en la transformación de
la patria empresarios sindicalistas
jueces periodistas artistas y líderes de
la sociedad civil sucumbieron ante el
poder de la billetera del estado cientos
miles de millones de dólares repartidos
entre los bolsillos de aquellos que
apoyaban y se manifestaban
incondicionales de este peculiar
matrimonio un entramado cliente lista
aceitado engrasado por concesiones
ayudas y subsidios convenientemente
repartidos y que nadie controlaba ahora
bien la pregunta que obligatoriamente
tenemos que hacernos es como lo
financiaban como hicieron los kirchner
para mantener semejante trama clientela
atentos compramos 300 vagones
kilómetros cada uno de estos vagones no
salió un millón 90 mil dólares
el pelotazo de la obra pública
[Música]
fijaos en lo que decía en el año 2010 la
propia cristina fernández de kirchner
para nosotros para esta administración
la obra pública no es una contingencia
es una convicción un concepto político
estructural que hemos venido
desarrollando no solamente desde 2003
sino desde que nos tocó la
responsabilidad de dirigir los destinos
de una comunidad cristina fernández de
kirchner ahora lo sabemos ahora sabemos
por qué era tan importante para este
matrimonio la obra pública y no lo
siento pero no tiene nada que ver con
los intereses del país la obra pública
era una de las partes centrales del
entramado político de los kirchner
primero 'santa cruz' y luego en toda la
argentina
ahora bien seguro que alguno de vosotros
está preguntando pero enrique cómo
funcionaba el sistema pues veréis en el
fondo era bastante sencillo el
presidente kirchner por medio de su
ministro de planificación federal e
inversión pública julio de vido que
además lo fue durante toda la etapa de
los kirchner al frente del país se
reunía periódicamente con las
principales empresas constructoras de la
argentina que a su vez eran convocadas
por el presidente de la cámara
la construcción carlos wagner pues bien
en estas reuniones a córdoba que empresa
exactamente se llevaría a cada
licitación pública es decir para
entendernos se repartían el pastel en
los despachos
y luego ya cuando estaba todo decidido
se convocaba el concurso público pero
esto era algo simplemente cosmético
siempre resultaba ganador a la empresa
que se había acordado previamente por
esta especie de cartel de la obra
pública
y ahora viene la clave de todo el
proceso una vez otorgada la obra las
empresas cobraban la primera cuota del
contrato el pago adelantado para
supuestamente poder empezar las obras
sin embargo este pago se entregaba
íntegramente a los políticos uno de los
motores del crecimiento en estos años ha
sido sin lugar a dudas la construcción
no solamente con la inversión del sector
privado sino el estado un momento
entonces donde estaba el negocio si
estas empresas tenían que devolver lo
que cobraban pues en el sobrecoste
[Música]
veréis se calcula que en promedio el
sobrecoste de cada obra rondaba entre el
30 y el 40 por ciento de la factura
total de esta manera si una obra era
concedida por 100 millones se aprobaban
ampliaciones en el presupuesto hasta un
total de aproximadamente 140 millones
pero eso no es todo
luego en ocasiones el gobierno además
aprobaba cambios y nuevas ampliaciones
en el proyecto hasta que la empresa que
se había adjudicado la obra por 100
millones terminaba cobrando muchísimo
más 180 200 250
incluso 28 veces el presupuesto inicial
es decir en este ejemplo 280 millones y
eso que muchas de estas obras ni
siquiera se terminaba tal cual como lo
escucháis por supuesto a cambio de este
hecho yo las empresas pagaban en coimas
a los políticos según los casos entre el
10 y el 20% del importe facturado por
cierto viendo lo visto os habéis
preguntado cómo funciona en vuestro país
la obra pública el caso amigos es que
todo este proceso funciona a la
perfección durante años pero ahora ha
quedado al descubierto tendría que cesar
me detuve para hacer una buena división
de política siempre me he sentido muy
orgullosa de ser parte de esta
formidable clase media argentina pujante
emprende y de paso dirigirme a todos
amigos compañeros y funcionarios que
tengan algunos bolsillos en plazo fijos
no te moreno no bueno
[Aplausos]
al descubierto
amigos los pequeños detalles cuentan
cuando no se cuidan todos los detalles
hasta las complejas e ingeniosas
operaciones corren el riesgo de venirse
abajo y este caso no ha sido una
excepción veréis resulta que el chofer
que transportaba al recaudador del
gobierno que iba a buscar las coimas los
maletines tenía la obsesión de anotar
cada viaje cada parada cada edificio
visitado el nombre de las personas que
iban a ver para la entrega de los
maletines incluso las conversaciones que
escuchaba durante sus viajes todo
prácticamente todo lo tenía anotado en
ocho cuadernos no se sabe si lo hacía
por impulso por entretenerse si formaba
parte de una especie de sistema de
control y contabilidad o simplemente
quería cubrirse las espaldas pero en
estos ocho cuadernos estaban apuntados
todos los detalles de esta trama mafiosa
y finalmente esos cuadernos llegaron a
manos de un periodista que al ver lo que
contenían decidió entregarlos a la
justicia y tras un trabajo de meses de
investigación a finales de julio de 2018
comenzaron las detenciones de altos
funcionarios y empresarios vinculados
con la trama
pero eso no es todo ahora muchas de
estas personas han decidido colaborar
con la justicia a cambio de beneficios
penitenciarios como por ejemplo
continuar en libertad y no en la cárcel
mientras continúa el proceso y uno de
ellos ha sido precisamente carlos wagner
el presidente de la cámara de
construcción la persona que convocaba a
las empresas que participaban en la
trama y uno de los que más se benefició
de todo este tinglado su relato amigos
confirmó todo lo que decía en los
cuadernos y el resto de testimonios van
en una línea similar pero ahora bien
seguro que os estáis preguntando vale
vale enrique pero de cuánto dinero
estamos hablando pues amigos de mucho
pero que mucho dinero veréis y carlos
wagner dice la verdad los kirchner
habían recibido casi 3 millones de
dólares 3 millones de dólares diarios
durante sus doce años y medio en el
gobierno es decir en total más de 12 mil
millones de dólares tan sólo con las
obras públicas porque además sospechas
de corrupción y casos pendientes hay
muchísimos más
mira
12000 millones para pagar a políticos
jueces periodistas líderes sociales y
por supuesto también para llenarse el
bolsillo todo apunta a que es así como
los kirchner hicieron y consolidaron su
poder sobre la argentina
ahí tenemos por ejemplo el caso de josé
lópez ex secretario de obras públicas y
una persona muy cercana a julio de vido
el ministro kirchnerista que gestionaba
la trama pues bien en junio de 2016 ha
alertado de que la policía podría llenar
su vivienda en el marco de una
investigación decidió salir de su casa a
las tres de la mañana con 99 millones de
dólares que tenía en efectivo debajo del
colchón que se sentirá teniendo 9
millones de dólares en efectivo ahí en
tu casa
desde luego dinero para pagar al
repartidor de pizzas no le faltaba pues
bien el caso es que esa madrugada trató
de esconder el dinero en un convento en
el convento de las monjas orantes y
penitentes de nuestra señora del rosario
de fátima con tan mala suerte que
mientras se estaba metiendo el dinero un
vecino que pensó que se trataba de un
robo llamó a la policía y así es como el
bueno de josé lópez fue pillado
infraganti ahora ya sabemos
probablemente de dónde procedía todo ese
dinero
[Música]
por cierto como os podéis imaginar este
dinero no se podía ingresar en el banco
con una simple transferencia no había
que pagarlo en efectivo en dólares por
eso de no dejar rastros así que se
trasladaba en bolsos pues bien como los
pagos eran tan regulares los encargados
de llenar los bolsos sabían ya
perfectamente cuántos paquetes de dinero
entraban en cada bolso así que parece
ser que el dinero se contaba no ya en
millones sino directamente el número de
bolsos
por cierto no os olvidéis que las
empresas también ganaban con los
sobreprecios así que el daño para los
argentinos ha sido muchísimo mayor en
fin amigos
esta es la truculenta historia de como
unos políticos decidieron saquear su
país de confirmarse los hechos quedaría
claro que aquí en la argentina
astados underwood se escandalizarían
terminará cristina fernández de kirchner
en la cárcel sólo el tiempo nos lo podrá
decir de momento como senadora goza de
inmunidad pero es muy posible que
próximamente la cámara del senado decida
quitarle sus fueros y la expresidenta
todopoderosa pueda ser juzgada amigos si
os ha resultado interesante este vídeo
no olvidéis darle a like y por cierto si
quieres conocer más sobre el peronismo
no te pierdas los dos vídeos que hemos
hecho sobre este movimiento político
este es el primero y antes de terminar
muchas gracias a nuestro amigo alejandro
gómez por ayudarnos a preparar este
vídeo ahora sí un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]
no logramos tenemos convicciones tenemos
ideas y no lucramos no estamos en el
negocio de la política estamos en la
transformación de la paz